JZ explains why he was unfaithful to
Beyonce plus we're breaking down the
Avengers infinity war trailer and the
future of the Marvel superheroes hi
friends this is the daily deni I cannot
believe that the years almost come into
an end but let's face it I'm over 2017
and while it will be hard to find what
was the best of the year
Instagram did release its year review
this morning and it turns out beyonce
has the most like photo of the year she
got more than 11 million likes for her
February announcement that she was
pregnant with twins while my recreation
of the now iconic photo racked up 249 so
I'm basically Beyonce meanwhile our
husband jay-z is getting very candid
again fresh off his whopping eight
Grammy nominations the most of any
artists this year hope is opening up
about what led him to be unfaithful to
his marriage to Beyonce in an interview
with t the New York Times Style magazine
Jay reveals he was able to find a good
therapist through a friend where he
realized some of his own demons and his
upbringing led him to shut down
emotionally when it came to his
relationships quote so you go into
survival mode and when you go into
survival mode what happens you shut down
all emotions so even with women they're
gonna shut down emotionally so you can't
connect in my case like it's deep and
then all the things happen from their
infidelity and as fate would have it out
of that infidelity came two of the most
honest and there I say brilliant albums
of the last couple years I'm talking
about of course lemonade and jay-z's 444
we've picked him proud of these records
already on this show we already know
what they're about and not surprisingly
the rapper admits listening to that
music made them both very very
uncomfortable he says they were using
their art as a therapy session but get
this
Jay reveals at the time they were
working on a collab album people but B's
music was further along and it became
what it became now Jay also got candid
about his rocky relationship with
frequent collaborator Kanye West while
he reveals he talked to Kanye the other
day and said he loves him Jim it's
there's currently tension quote but that
happens and the long relationship you
know hope
we when were 89 we look at this six
months or whatever time and we laugh at
that there's gonna be complications in
the relationship that we have to get
through post says they're always gonna
be good though so we'll see which joint
album are we gonna get first Beyonce and
jay-z or Watch the Throne - I want both
I need both gimme gimme gimme
okay that was a lot to get through you
guys but let's marvel at some other
folks teaming up together and Avengers
infinity war you see what I did there we
got a new trailer and I got a little
peak for you guys take a look
[Music]
evacuate the city
and gates or defenses
and get this man a sheet
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers from
balancing the universe
josh brolin Santos is wreaking havoc
guys it is not looking good but someone
who is a resident movie expert Ash
crosses I look like an agent of shield
okay
raise your hand if you woke up at 4:00
a.m. to watch this bad boy because I did
we have been waiting for this since July
and my heartstrings are tugged because
this really looks like the beginning of
the end of the Avengers as we know them
Thanos is the Marvel Cinematic Universe
as ultimate villain he's been teased
since the first Avengers in 2012 and now
he's here he's on earth he's vacuuming
up those Infinity stones like freakin
candy and I think the question on
everyone's mind is will the Avengers
make it out alive I mean if they want
those paychecks I think they're gonna
stick around but we've got some major
hints on the franchise with this
spectacular Marvel spread in Vanity Fair
it features the Marvel Super Heroes on
for exclusive covers and in the article
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige drop
some hints coin adventures for a finale
and Mark Ruffalo seen all good things
must come to an end right and that makes
you think dead or hopefully retired
Avengers in addition to that you've got
to think about behind the scenes I mean
how much longer did Chris Evans and
Robert Downey jr. etc want to be
involved in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I think we could definitely see
Bucky or Falcon taking over for cap or
you know Tony Stark in the mentoring
Peter Parker third they're really
setting up that next phase of Marvel and
we've certainly been introduced to a lot
of new characters lately that could take
the reins Tessa Thompson what a positive
spin or what possibly could be these
saddest - of any movies ever so we will
hold our breath until then it's over
doing it now okay thanks ash alright
thank you catch your breath are you guys
moving on to the Royal Wedding today I
swear I thought I was gonna take a break
from talking about Prince Harry and mega
Marvel's engagement however that is
until I learned what Prince William
really thinks of his brother time to not
watch his reaction when chatting with
ITV's Chris ship the Apple very excited
delighted for the face
and pushing them all the happiness in
this very exciting time and for me
personally I hope it means he stays out
of my fridge there's something standing
up for my food he's only the last few
years apparently little Harry is a food
thief lucky for William
Harry's bride-to-be is apparently a
really good cook she was after all
roasting a chicken when Harry proposed
so your fridge should be restocked in no
time Billy alright folks thanks for
watching today I don't say this enough
but find me on Twitter and Instagram at
D direct o if you're not tired of me by
the end of this video but while I got
you here be sure to like and share and
of course subscribe to our channel for
more entertainment goodies goodies wow I
can't talk goodbye
[Music]